Why are South Korean women having fewer babies?
Well, there are a lot of reasons behind,...
...a lot of reasons behind South Korea's birth rate crisis.
There is sky-high housing prices.
They make it a lot (harder) for a lot of young people to have a place to live...
...and find a place to live together.
Or there's an enormous cost of child rearing that make a lot of young people...
...to give up on the idea of having a child to begin with.
And there is this so long working hours that a lot of, notoriously long working hours...
...that make a lot of young people to think that, rightfully so,...
...that they are having work-life balance is almost impossible to have...
...including having a child and having a career, at the same time.
But there is also a very one important factor behind this crisis...
...is that the gender inequality that is very deeply ingrained...
...in the country's family culture and family life...
...that puts extremely disproportionate burden of child care...
...and domestic responsibility on these women.
And also coupled with the rampant discrimination against women...
...especially married women and working mothers in a lot of South Korean workplaces...
...make a lot of young women to shun the child first and even marriage altogether.